bonjour je m'appelle morin de voiliers
je suis auteur compositeur interprète je
fais de la musique
ben je fais ça depuis que je suis toute
petite je viens tout juste de sortir mon
tout premier album qui s'appelle bazar
donc j'ai sorti un premier single
sentimentale et ensuite mon deuxième
single de l'album s'appelle brûler toute
cette chanson pour moi elle est un coup
de gueule un cri du coeur une façon de
manifester ma colère il de la guérir
aussi voulait que tout ça se sent dans
le titre l'oci dans le refrain du coup
il ya une phrase qui est assez agressive
c'est plus une impulsion c'était pour
moi une façon de faire table rase de
tous les symboles et de toutes les
manifestations de l'époque coloniale je
voulais pas que ça ça va être cachée
nous pour moi c'est une chanson qui a du
sens aussi dans tous les cas où il y à
un oppresseur qui a fait ou qui fait
pression sur les plus faibles et ça
s'applique beaucoup à la colonisation et
à tous les méfaits
alors la chanson s'adresse à beaucoup de
choses en même temps si je prends le cas
de la phrase guy les yeux tout elle ne
s'adresse pas à des gens bien au
contraire et s'adresse à des symboles
par exemple que ce soit le drapeau 400
ports ou des figures de l'époque
coloniale qui sont encore très très
blessantes aujourd'hui parce qu'il faut
pas oublier que c'est une période qui
n'a que quelques années maintenant le
réseau la chanson hormis le brio tout
s'adresse à toutes les personnes que ce
soit des politiciens des personnes qui
ont beaucoup de pouvoir en général et
qui ne l'utilisent pas à bon escient
donc je ne vise pas des gens en
particulier ce n'est pas nominatif parce
que c'est surtout au final le système
qui a dénoncé si je prends l'exemple de
la fraise rend l'argent je me suis
clairement inspiré d'une période
à l'époque sur twitter et sur instagram
où on disait rend l'argent par rapport
aux politiciens qu'ils avaient d'une
manière ou d'une autre
voler l'argent des contribuables le
message que je veux faire passer c'est
un peu on ne veut plus d'une martinique
qui subit on veut des jeunes actifs
prêts à défendre leur ville à construire
chez eux parce que pour moi le combat
entre guillemets sera gagnée dès lors
qu'il y aura un maximum de mardi
niquet et de martiniquaise qui auront
réussi à faire leurs projets ce titre
m'est venue l'année dernière j'avais
besoin d'exprimer cette colère là parce
que c'est un sujet que j'aborde tout le
temps que ce soit dans ma famille ou
dans mes amis voilà pour moi ce n'est
pas un changement de style à proprement
parler parce que je n'ai pas toujours
écrit sur l'amour est en fait il ya une
chanson prend chaque humeur et puis les
autres ben voilà c'est aussi c'est de la
colère c'est de la motivation c'est
plein de choses en même temps
l'accueil de tout m'a surpris je les
sorties très peu de temps après
sentimentale il a eu un accueil assez
impressionnant si bien que sur les
premiers chiffres on voit que ça dépasse
sentimentale et puis au final bien la
cueillette ensuite mitigé parce que ben
l'amalgamé facile
et puis il n'y a pas eu de la diffusion
média que sentimentale a pu avoir un
mieux au final j'ai eu beaucoup de
retours positifs notamment de ma
communauté en tout cas la plupart des
personnes ont apprécié et ont compris le
message je suis très fier quand même
d'avoir sorti ce morceau malgré les
interprétations parfois un peu erronée
alors je n'ai pas hésité à afficher mon
soutien à keziah parce que j'estime
qu'il a été victime de violences
policières ce qui pour moi est
inadmissible pendant que j'étais à paris
je suis allé à une manifestation pour
adama traoré
c'est un sujet qui me touche énormément
et je pense qu'ils touchent la plupart
d'entre nous maintenant j'ai pas honte
d'utiliser mes réseaux pour parler de ça
avec l'idée d'être pacifiques dans la
démarche
je ne me considère pas comme une artiste
engagée je me considère juste comme une
martiniquaise qui aime son pays et comme
une femme noire dans une société où
malheureusement on n'a pas encore les
qualités que l'on éviterait je ne vais
pas me cacher derrière un masque donc
c'est tout simplement moi et je pense
que la plupart des personnes ont des
convictions qui mérite d'être entendue